okay I'm just gonna interrupt you Johnny  if I may because John I'm just gonna  have to Barnaby if you found it somebody  can tell Barbie they're bringing them  through the opposite door and I'm just  moving down as quickly as I can  police are stopping the press people are  falling over to stand up for you they  literally shoving people out of the way  people are walkie talkies and also  but it's all one of the women has now  been knocked over and is pleasantly on  the floor this is one of the family  members  and he can't move absolute panda me  I'm running up the escalator night to  try and get to the top so then we can  bring you those pictures if we can  should I go into the gym here we go top  of the stairs okay take your Knights of  the road being guided back again  absolutely  and loved ones are 239 cells remember  onboard that aircraft these two ladies  had loved ones on board in the last 12  days they've been given no information  whatsoever